Now that we know how to save,
we're pretty much set.
One thing to keep in mind though
as we mentioned before is that
when you save this is where
what you're saving is validated
against the data model you've created.
So this means if the object you're
saving doesn't have everything the model
says it should or it doesn't fit
the model's description of what it
should be,
you'll be looking at an app crash.
This is where it's important
to recheck your model and
make sure things match up.
>> One of the most common places for
this issue to arise is with deletion.
Let's take a look at our model again.
The deletion rule for our notebooks
notes relationship is cascade.
This means it will delete
all the associated notes.
That sounds reasonable.
If we look at the inverse relationship
that notebook relationship with a note
the deletion rule is nullified.
This means that when a note is deleted,
all the references to it are removed or
made no.
The notebook just
forgets about that note.
This also sounds reasonable.
But what if by mistake, we set the note
deletion rule to cascade also?
Then if we delete a notebook, core
data it will try to delete the notes.
However, if the note
deletion rule is cascade,
core data will then try to
delete the notebook again.
Trying to delete an object twice
is a sure recipe for an app crash.
This is a very common beginner mistake,
so
make sure your deletion
rules make sense.